well this morning Gary lineker has
tweeted his response he wrote after a
surreal few days I'm delighted that
we've navigated our way through this I
want to thank you all for the incredible
support particularly my colleagues at
BBC sport for the remarkable show of
solidarity football's a team game but
their backing was overwhelming I've been
presenting sport on the BBC for almost
three decades and I'm immeasurably proud
to work with the best and fairest
broadcaster in the world I cannot wait
to get back in the match of the day
chair on Saturday former conservative MP
Anna subrier joins me now to discuss
this um and it seems like two sides have
found a compromise both in the short
term and potentially in the long term
with an independent review of their
social media guidelines uh to come is
that a good outcome for all here
well it seems it looks like Common Sense
has broken out and that's to be hugely
welcomed I I I mean I've got a lot of
time for Tim Davey and I think it's
difficult but he does have questions
that he must answer because the
perception has been was that the BBC
gave in to political pressure from the
government that was the perception now
either that's it's I there either did or
they didn't to me it looked like they
had done because if what lineker had
tweeted out was so bad then why didn't
they suspend him earlier last week and
there are some big questions about the
way that the beep have conducted
themselves throughout the whole of this
affair but the end of the day this is a
good result it's great to have Linda
coming back to do match of the day if
you like football I do I think he's a
superb broadcaster and so it's good to
have him back I don't think they should
have suspended him but we are where we
are and moving forward to use that awful
expression it is right that the BBC
should have
um this inquiry so that people know what
the rules are uh and you know they can
have a couple of debate about all of
this
that's where I was going to come to next
which is that clearly now everyone
thinks there is a need to review this
this set of policy and remove any any
gray areas that that clearly exist is
that not the biggest error of whoever is
in charge at the BBC that those rules
existed with a gray area which were only
introduced in 2020 it's not like these
have been a legacy set of rules since
the pre-social media age and that Tim
Davey took over yesterday is that set of
uh gray areas that can lead to this sort
of situation his his biggest error well
I I say I agree with you
was that if you're presenting news
programs involved in current affairs
then you should be absolutely seen to be
impartial and not tweet out or go and
make any other comments that might in
some way
um undermine or jeopardize your
impartiality and there are different not
rules but you know he's a sports
presenter for the sake
um the problem was and I have to put my
hands up I hadn't realized this but was
that actually that so-called Graham as
you put it which is if you've got a
particular uh Publix
um Persona because you are a BBC
presenter which is all a bit woolly then
you've got to watch yourself and that's
where they say they they catch someone
like Gary lineker but that didn't
account for the what sound not well it
is hypocritical profound hypocrisy of
Alan sugar who presents The Apprentice
which is a high-profile BBC program
telling people
but saying to people back in 2019 vote
conservative nobody got themselves into
it as it is about that and of course you
always had the position of Andrew Neal
who knows with Channel 4 but was with
BBC for donkeys years who was the editor
of The Spectator and nobody seemed to
have any problem with the fact that
Andrew real did that job and his views
were quite widely known but it didn't
stop him of course
and I've always thought he was
incredibly fair and impartial in the job
that he did so certainly people like me
didn't make too many complaints about
that and then we've got people like
Chris Packham and then you start to get
into areas of Brian Cox and then do you
have fabulous actors doing work on the
BBC with high profiles and so it is a
mess but I think they can work it out
and put it into proportion yeah really
because the Sports presenter for God's
sakes albeit um of course the sugar
issue happened in 2019 before the new
regulations in 2020 and I I think Andrew
was chairman of the company as opposed
to editor of the magazine which is which
is right now just a quick final point it
doesn't matter you make a good point
just a quick final point though
and I don't know who this blame goes to
because we've all been talking about it
but do we care too much because it's the
BBC I mean the issue here surely is that
of com regulations apply to all
broadcasters in the news space uh the
BBC has an additional fact that it's
public funded does that at secondary
aspect make a legitimate amount of
difference or not well because there are
National broadcasters and you know great
companies like sky and the work that you
do you're you are in a different
position because you you're more of a
subscription service and you're not paid
for by the license fee and and the BBC
is in a different position to other
other organizations other broadcasters
um but I mean to be I mean just being
blunt about this I mean I think the way
the BBC have conducted it has been
appalling just in their own broadcast
terms I mean they made this an
extraordinary huge story they were
leading on it you guys weren't leading
on it and rightly so you you were doing
that stories but you're also looking at
the actual issue which was the
government's actual bill in its
proposals but the beep as ever just
engages in this bizarre Naval gating and
it just doesn't he didn't get a grip on
it and then it gave it far too many legs
to run and it looks thankfully like you
know calm Common Sense has now prevailed
and Lynette who's back on screen which
is great bad news perhaps for sky but
but great for the BBC and football fans
no no we welcome the competition I agree
not as good as our sports broadcasters
though uh but Anna thank you so much uh
for for joining us very much uh very
much appreciated and uh one other little
clarification as well the Sky News is
not a subscription and is available to
all for free as I'm sure you viewers
have